foreign
[Music]
do they really mean to invade us
the archduke's son
foreign
it's impossible
the legacy of the crystals
the Shaker history
foreign
[Music]
who are we
what are the dominance the power we
wield
it wears away at our very being it
breaks us it unmakes us that it's
Immaculate aspect might reveal itself
the icon
there's going to be another War isn't
there
every day we delay brings us closer to
disaster we must move now
[Applause]
the chaos he would wreak would Sweep All
of valisthea into the abyss
I unite the dominance but we may bring
an end to the strife and found a new
order to see us onto tomorrow
if I take the field
our deal will shake the island
to its foundations
[Music]
foreign
yet for every citizen who Falls
another can be read
every home that burns another can be
built
the Empire will live on
[Music]
awaken child of fate
awakened
hear free
[Music]
1500 years since the fall of our
forebears
and Valencia has been slow
ever since
[Music]
almost further now but we're in the
middle of the deadlands the blinds of
this place dry and in Old trees no birds
and no matching
Darkness spreads as day gives way to
Twilight
the mother's flame now all but a flicker
we can uplift without the blessing of
the crystals
the crystals work their magic through us
you have been blessed Joshua but who
shall claim their fading light
the grand duchy of Rosaria Bastion of
tradition at the very least we must
secure Drake's breath the holy
ambition is
Imperial Banner shall fly over every
city in storm
all shall bow before their end the
dalmekian Republic whose fortunes shift
with the desert sands
and what if our wise rulers goaded into
war without any thought as to what chaos
it might reap the iron Kingdom forged in
faith and fear their souls were sullied
with this stain of ether
I merely cleanse them of their
corruption
indomitable in its oscillation the dark
swallows more of the realm with each
passing day and as the fringes fade the
people flocked to the mother crystals
from a single Spark
will the land ignite
in the year 860.
the Imperial Army will March upon
Rosaria
and from the slaughter shall a new
Shadow rise
fall upon the dominance
painting their Destinies black as
nightability to summon beasts of great
light should command respect but it's
but instead has left us outcasts
and so I became their puppet
what makes them think they have the
right to use us to leave us to die when
our bodies are spent I'll crush him
[Music]
thank you
it is you who shall bow to me very well
show us the strength of your will
by the crownless Kings a reckoning is
upon you
a war
of the icons
take Joshua and get to safety
I've got to hold the enemy here while
you make you escape
your highness
run
[Music]
revenge is a weapon
I sometimes wonder if I am controlling
it or if it's controlling me
[Music]
no matter how better the truth that
awaits me
I will Press On
good boy
what do we do the usual
13 years I've waited for this chance and
I will be dying today
come to me you're free
[Music]
more than a decade final fantasy has
been gradually shedding parts of its
turn-based RPG roots and embracing a
more action-oriented Direction it was
only a matter of time before that focus
on action took precedence over the
role-playing elements and it appears
that Final Fantasy XV is finally the
moment the ratio has flipped as a
longtime fan of the traditional Final
Fantasy games I wasn't quite sure what
to think of this development the
turn-based classics are still some of my
favorite gaming experiences of all time
but after an extensive Hands-On with the
game I've come around on this direction
for the series or at least this entry in
it
if Final Fantasy is an action franchise
now at least it's shaping up to be a
damn good one this isn't to say the game
lacks Fantastical elements like mythical
beasts and magic spells but those are
used to complement the story in action
rather than as a layer of menu
abstraction in the fictional High
fantasy world of valastia an extremely
small number of Mortals are innately
gifted as dominance hosts for
Supernatural icons which long time Final
Fantasy fans will recognize as summoned
creatures icons are essentially weapons
of mass destruction and the various
nation-states use their icons as symbols
of their power and culture the dominance
are respected feared and sometimes even
exploited by their respective Nations as
the implied threat of the icons keeps
other nations in check the protagonist
Clive's brother Joshua was given a place
of honor as the dominant of Phoenix the
aspect of fire Cloud's journey is one of
Revenge as an attack from an invading
Army and a mysterious previously unseen
icon left his younger brother dead my
play session took place when Clive was
in his 20s obsessed with vengeance and
throwing his lot in with revolutionaries
who are looking to overthrow the social
order this segment of the story tightly
focused on just three major characters
which helped illustrate how the
political and magical machinations play
out amid the interpersonal relationships
Clive was accompanied by sidolphus
taloman this game Sid another Final
Fantasy Mainstay who is both a freedom
fighter for Magical refugees and the
dominant of Rama the aspect of lightning
their mission brought them to a castle
guarded by benedicta Harmon the doorman
of Garuda aspect of win and apparently
Sid's Old Flame Clive was also
accompanied by his loyal and very good
boy dog torgel who acts as a consistent
companion character in battle
if it seems like I'm focusing heavily on
the story it's because I find that
aspect interesting right from the start
the best final fantasy stories use
Fantastical elements to say something
about the human condition and nation
states having entered an uneasy Cold War
as each of them Harbor their own
personal living breathing wmds is a
fascinating hook that feels relatable to
real life conflicts the fact that some
Nations worship their dominance and
others imprisoned them as Living Weapons
speaks to the breadth of how we treat
things we don't understand on top of
that these super-powered beings have
their own human lives and relationships
which adds yet another wrinkle to every
interaction it's the interplay of all
these disparate elements that stands out
the most and made me care about the
characters as I explored an engaging
story wouldn't amount to much without a
strong battle system them to back it up
and on that front I was more skeptical
in Final Fantasy 16 you control one
character Clive Rosefield and the entire
story revolves around his perspective as
he matures over the course of decades
the singular focus on Clive as the sole
protagonist sometimes but not always
flanked by ai-controlled companion
characters seem to indicate a
de-emphasis on juggling commands from
party members with disparate skill sets
which is part of the joy of a
traditional Final Fantasy game final
fantasy 16 replaces this level of
strategic intensity with a battle system
that feels naturally action based but
with the underpinnings of choice as
Clive proceeds through the story he
picks up abilities from the different
icons he Encounters this doesn't make
him their dominant but it does mean that
his fighting style will be imbued with
magical flourishes that embody their
unique traits for the demo he had
blessings of Phoenix fire Garuda wind
and Titan Earth you can swap between
these on the Fly and use their unique
spell abilities to complement your array
of melee attacks Phoenix for example is
particularly agile and able to close
gaps while Garuda is better for air
juggles and reaching out with its
harpy-like claws to grab enemies from
afar
Titan feels very different from both of
these with heavy attacks that often
require a brief charge to deliver their
full impact the combat system not only
allows but demands that you sweep
between these abilities since each of
them has its own cooldown that will be
in various states of recharging while
you swap to another but the cooldowns
were generous you're clearly intended to
use the full Suite of moves quickly and
to swap between them constantly at first
I found swapping between these
disorienting especially when I would tap
a Titan ability having forgotten it
requires a Charged buttonhole instead
but after only a couple of hours it felt
much more natural and I could see room
for a great deal of flexibility in the
system
each of the icon abilities along with
Clive's standard melee attacks has its
own upgrade tray I explored the tree and
upgraded a few moves unlocking new
combat abilities and enhancing the
strength of some of my favorite moves
choosing which icons to equip and how to
upgrade them looks as if it will provide
ample strategic decision making in the
moments between battles if anything I
was spoiled for Choice as the upgrade
options looked like equally exciting and
fun ways to mix up my Arsenal moves
these choices then pay off with White
Knuckle to combat when you're in the
thick of a fight Square Enix boasts that
it brought on Devil May Cry veteran
ryota Suzuki as its battle designer and
the moment-to-moment melee combat mixed
with magical ranged abilities certainly
felt reminiscent of Dante and Nero the
game that most came to mind when I
played though was another action
franchise God of War that's because the
melee battles are punctuated by icon
battles uniquely built action set pieces
that feel markedly different than the
standard battles and are particularly
exciting while traversing the castle I
came face to face with benedicta and
enjoyably scenery chewing antagonist
with dramatic Flair benedicta first
called on the aspect of Garuda to a
limited degree turning into a super
power demi-human version of herself with
wings Sid met her in kind half
transforming into Rama resulting in a
class of super powered beings that still
look roughly like they're human
characters and still acting with their
own human motivations the ensuing battle
involved fighting two other harpy-like
creatures that she summoned and later
referred to as her sisters and then
progressed to fighting her in half icon
form on a tower rooftop it was a test of
skill for all I had learned up to that
point while also tossing in cinematic
story elements
one moment when Toro leaped to my
defense clenched his jaw around
benedicta's neck
was a real fist-pumping moment for me
which isn't a feeling I often associate
with this franchise her injuring and
then tossing my canine pal aside while
spitting a curse made me that much more
determined to destroy her of course this
all led to the real set piece moment an
icon on icon battle between Ifrit and
Garuda like all icon battles this was
crafted to be its own distinct encounter
pitting it for its ability and brute
strength against garuda's ability to
control the battlefield with the wind
and it was an absolute blast a Kaiju
Battle come to life with all the
dramatic underpinnings of the human
story that had informed it the
uniqueness of the encounter meant that I
was largely learning its mechanics on
the fly but this didn't feel like it was
meant to be challenging like the
traditional melee combat instead it was
made to be a spectacle and something to
reward all of the effort leading up to
that point
foreign
to the extent that this new more
action-heavy Focus might put on long
time fans of the series Square Enix has
come up with a pretty ingenious variable
difficulty system Final Fantasy 16 has a
story mode but unlike many games that
use that name for an easier difficulty
level it instead simply turns on a
couple of helpful assists these assists
are available whether you choose story
mode or not so turning them on simply
makes them the default but it's exactly
how these assists are implemented that
makes the system so smart instead of
menu options the assists are presented
as a series of five special rings that
Grant different types of assistance one
of them simplifies combat so that simply
pressing one button automatically
controls your combos for example while
another extends the window for a
successful Dodge you can equip these
rings in your three accessory slots but
that means you'll always have more rings
than you have space to put them in
you'll have to choose which if any to
use to make combat easier on you this
also presents an opportunity cost as
each slot taken up by one of the assist
strings is one fewer accessory you can
use to customize Clive's other abilities
the whole system seems thoughtful and
elegant letting you still feel the
thrill of combat while gently nudging
you towards removing the training wheels
as you get more comfortable this new
focus on action combat does come at a
price though Square NX has already
stated that Final Fantasy 16 doesn't use
an open world structure which may remove
some of the expansive scope and awe of
the traditional Final Fantasy game my
play session consisted of a fairly
straightforward level design with only
brief side paths to discover some
treasures and then proceed along the
main path The Producers noted that the
full game has wider spaces which should
provide a sense of exploration but I
didn't experience them for myself a
narrower level structure may just be the
nature of the genre shift as Final
Fantasy 16 crosses the threshold into
full-fledged action spectacle some
aspects are bound to feel different than
RPG fans have grown accustomed to for
this RPG fan though the change of pace
is welcome who knows what the future
holds for Final Fantasy but I'm
convinced that this is the right
direction for this entry in the
franchise I went in as a doubter and
came out as a True Believer eager to
experience the ride
foreign
you all know the target shiva's dominant
and only the dominant
how do we even know the girl will be a
monk
Our Kind do not question orders we
follow them
Sergeant let's summoned their icon
I picked a bloody Mountain
[Music]
oh
foe will not relinquish their mother
Crystal easily
this will be a bitter fight
you should not be out of doors
we have discussed this
come Joshua
your father will be expecting us
I am Joshua's Shield
[Music]
I'm sworn to protect him
what do you mean you refuse
did you not pledge your thoughts
what does it matter
it was the dalmax who daught back the
Crusaders in the bath of the twin Realms
wasn't it
without the blessing of the mother
Crystal we cannot defend our realm from
the spread of the blood
[Music]
Imperial vipers
do they really mean to invade us
it's the hot Duke's son
foreign
the legacy of the crystals
shaped our history
no enough
I'll kill you
if it's the last thing I do
[Music]
foreign
aspect might reveal itself
the icon
there's going to be another War isn't
there
every day we delay brings us closer to
this
we must move now
[Applause]
the chaos he would read would Sweep All
of Valencia into the abyss
[Music]
foreign
but we may bring an end to the strife
and found a new order to see us onto
tomorrow
if I take the field
how would you shake the island
its foundations
thank you
there will be losses it is true
yet for every citizen who Falls
another can be bred
every home that burns another can be
built
the Empire will live on
[Music]
awaken child of Fate
awakened every
[Music]
bit
it has been 1500 years since the fall of
our forebears
has been slowly dying
ever since
[Music]
almost further now but we're in the
middle of the deadlands the blanks of
this place dry and in Old trees no birds
and no matching
Darkness spreads as day gives way to
Twilight
the mother's flame now all but a flicker
we can uplift
the blessing of the crystals
the crystals work their magic through us
you have been blessed Joshua but who
shall claim their fading light the grand
duchy of Rosaria Bastion of tradition at
the very least we must secure Drake's
breath the holy Empire of
[Music]
material banish or fly over every city
in storm
all shall bow before their end
the dalmekian Republic
fortunes
and what if our wise rules goaded into
war without any thought as to what chaos
it might reap the iron Kingdom forged in
faith and fear their souls were sullied
with this stain of ether I merely
cleanse them of their corruption or the
kingdom of wulud indomitable in its
isolation the dark swallows more of the
realm with each passing day
and as the fringes fade the people flock
to the mother crystals
from a single Spark
will the land ignite
in the year
860.
the Imperial Army will March upon Rose
area
and from the slaughter shall a new
Shadow rise
fall upon the dominance
painting their Destinies black as
nightability to summon beasts of great
light should command respect but instead
has left us outcasts
and so I became their puppet
what makes them think they have the
right to use us to leave us to die when
our bodies are spent I'll crush him
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Final Fantasy 16 and welcome to the
state of play today I'm here to talk a
little bit about the story world and
combat system of Final Fantasy 16 as
well as who will be our all new
information regarding the game's wide
variety of RPG elements and support
systems we'll be talking you through
everything while using never before seen
gameplay footage running on the
PlayStation 5. I hope you'll stay with
us until the end of the show and enjoy
everything we have in store for you with
that let's get started
you all know the target
shiva's dominant
and only the dominant
Focus wyvern
you are key to this mission's success
yes sergeant
I said Focus wyvern
[Music]
sweet home
allow me to welcome you to the world of
Final Fantasy 16.
Final Fantasy XV is the latest
installment in the Final Fantasy series
a storied franchise with 35 years of
History yet while this is the 16th
Mainline title in the series there's
absolutely no need to have played any of
the previous games before jumping in
with a fusion of real-time action and
RPG features Final Fantasy 16 has been
developed as the first true action RPG
in the series
using the power of the PlayStation 5 to
its fullest the game delivers an
expansive thrilling gameplay experience
which we liken to a high-speed roller
coaster ride
foreign
[Music]
the protagonist of our story is Clive
rossfield and his journey takes place in
the realm of Valencia
we follow the Epic tale of Clive Shield
of the grand duchy of Rosaria as it
unfolds across three distinct periods in
Our Hero's life his teens 20s and 30s
[Music]
while the Story begins with Clive in his
twenties a fully playable flashback will
allow you to experience the pivotal
events that shaped his past and presence
and thus does the curtain open on this
newest Final Fantasy Adventure
Phoenix
[Music]
foreign
navigation in Final Fantasy 16 is driven
via a world map with locations being
added and updated as players progress
through the main narrative
the world map can be opened at any time
allowing players access to all manner of
locations across valastia
[Music]
here players will meet new friends
encounter formidable foes and uncover
great and wondrous Mysteries
[Music]
foreign
next I'd like to talk about the combat
of Final Fantasy XV
all the battles in the game take place
in real time and are not turn based
as five progresses through the story he
will learn a wide array of exciting
abilities from the icons that he
encounters
thank you
now let's take a moment to admire Clive
in action
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the abilities that Clive wields had
unique characteristics depending on the
icon they are derived from
players can use ability points collected
by defeating enemies to unlock more
abilities or upgrade existing ones
can't decide which iconic ability to
unlock or upgrade
no problem
you can let the game choose for you
[Music]
15 includes a range of timely
accessories to provide support to those
players who may not be so skilled at
action games bringing them a truly
enjoyable experience
players are encouraged to equip Clive
with different combinations of these
accessories until they find the one that
perfectly matches their own play style
a combination I can particularly
recommend to those who may struggle with
action gameplay is the ring of timely
focus and the Ring of timely strikes
this combination allows players to
unleash a wide array of different
techniques just by pressing a single
attack Button as well as shifting into a
window of slow motion whenever Clive is
about to be hit by an attack giving them
a little extra time to hit R1 and evade
alternatively players could equip an
accessory that fully automates evasion
as I said before I really encourage
everyone to discover the combination
that works best for them
and for those who want to concentrate on
the story don't forget to choose story
Focus mode before starting a new game
in this mode time accessories are
automatically equipped from the start
allowing players to immerse themselves
in the narrative experience without
having to worry too much with the action
foreign
will meet many characters along his
journey who will join him as friends and
allies
these are Fallen ruins
and it keeps the black from our lungs
and how do you survive without magic
said office who becomes a mentor to
Clive
[Music]
a friend from Clive's youth it really is
such encounters and reunions will set
Clive on a path of great personal growth
it is
[Music]
some of these companions will even
accompany Clive on his adventures
fighting alongside him and finding lots
to talk about along the way
that said players will only need to
focus on controlling climb party members
are fully AI driven providing support
for the hero and constantly adapting and
responding to his actions
[Music]
foreign
torgel is always by Clive's side and
willing to stand by him in the face of
whatever cruel fate May befall about
will act of his own accord but players
can also give him direct commands
just don't forget to give this good boy
some treats every now and then
goots
get her upstairs
well but none will don't fret about
Karen I've taken care of her fee all of
it she's the best dealer decided about
[Music]
go have a look around I'll be in my solo
after progressing somewhat through the
game Clive will gain access to Sid's
Hideaway
[Music]
here in the Hideaway Clive will find a
shop where he can purchase new weapons
armor and consumables such as potions
you cannot find a better price than that
well Blackthorne a highly skilled
blacksmith works the hideaway's forge
bring in materials to craft New Gear or
upgrade the existing items
after upgrading your equipment or
unlocking new abilities try accessing
the areta stone
[Music]
here players can enter a virtual
training area outside the bounds of time
and space where they are free to refine
and practice combos of their very own
once you're confident in your skills try
your hand at arcade mode and see how
your scores stack up against players
from around the world
The Hideaway is home to a lot of other
features as well
[Music]
not only will players discover a variety
of side quests here but they can also
view information on quests offered all
around ballastia
[Music]
thank you
all right Clive
still busy saving the world
mid
when did you get back
[Music]
ah I wasn't expecting you back so soon
foreign
[Music]
to gain information on Elite marks
fearsome foes lurking about the realm in
desperate need of slaying the Moogle
will be your guide
[Music]
there's also luresman Hippocrates who
will unlock vallastia's Secrets as Clive
recounts Tales of his adventures
[Music]
today
you wish to study the tones
[Music]
here for another of my lectures and
Vivian Ninetails what is it a scholar
and strategist who will be more than
happy to explain to Clive the current
state of the realm and provide
information on key players there are all
kinds of interactions and features in
the Hideaway to help players get even
more enjoyment out of their time with
Final Fantasy 16.
[Music]
on his travels Clive will encounter a
wide array of fearsome foes
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
he will of course clash with the
dominance who wield the power of the
icons
colossal beasts who hold the surrounding
lands under their sway
mysterious constructs of the Fallen a
civilization shrouded in mystery
temperatures
thank you
[Music]
and we cannot forget the icons
themselves
experience unparalleled real-time action
combat as Clive takes command of the
iconic might coursing through his veins
and shatters his very limits
[Music]
The Shining point of Final Fantasy XV
however has to be the breathtaking icon
vs icon battles
foreign
confrontations all play out in real time
allowing players to control their very
own icon with their own hands
foreign
s differ depending on the icon
encountered and every Showdown is unique
right down to gameplay players will
experience everything from a 3D
scrolling shooter to a heavyweight
wrestling match with devastating attacks
that Encompass the entire Battlefield
these massive scale boss battles are
entirely seamless and I can promise you
heart stopping controller gripping
excitement I can't wait for you to get
your hands on the game for yourself
[Music]
but if you can do it
foreign
[Music]
so everyone what did you think thank you
for taking the time to join us today
Final Fantasy 16 will be available
worldwide June 22nd and there's still
plenty that we've left to reveal battle
content side content endgame content and
more we hope to bring you more on these
aspects of the game in the near future
also I'm truly excited to finally be
able to reveal that Final Fantasy 16's
main theme was written and performed by
one of Japan's greatest recording
artists kenshi yonizen we've still got a
lot more in store for you in the coming
weeks and I hope you all pre-order the
game and join us in balastia on release
day this has been nauki Yoshida producer
of Final Fantasy 16. see you again
thank you